his name is synonymous with corporate
titan
he's an innovator he's an icon he's in
the same
category as the jb morgan's the
rockefellers
a pioneer who was instrumental in
creating a two and a half trillion
dollar industry henry kravis has
constantly pushed the envelope
he's helped define the private equity
industry
henry was ahead of everybody when it
came to raising money he sort of
invented the business
henry kravis led a fierce battle that
sent shockwaves
through wall street henry's decision to
enter the deal
as he did it was not just big guns
coming in
it was godzilla wading in from the ocean
and stomping down wall street he's a
fighter
and a competitive fighter he not only
changed the game
he made it better
[Music]
henry was at the forefront of the 80s
you look at henry today
it's the same story henry's right at the
top there was
no doubt in my mind that once he said he
was going to win
that deal he was going to win he's
making the big decisions
calling the shots he's been the one
instrumental in
taking risks over the years and pushing
them into
into new areas henry kravis opened up a
brand new frontier to investors
a a war chest greater than the gross
domestic product of many small countries
to this day he has rarely talked about
his work or his life publicly
and declined to participate in this
program
kravis was born in 1944 in the oil patch
of tulsa oklahoma
black gold was everywhere his father was
a petroleum engineer
who made his family a fortune allen ace
greenberg
former chairman of bear stearns has
known kravis for over
40 years there wasn't a major
institution in this country
that would make a loan against gas or
oil reserves
without speaking to him to his father
first
brian burrow is co-author of the
landmark financial drama of modern
business
the book barbarians at the gate from an
early age
he clearly as a man who had a very
successful father
wanted to show that he was every bit as
successful as his father was
kravis's road to success took him from
prep school in the northeast
to southern california in 1963.
he majored in economics at claremont
mckenna college
in a recent commencement address to his
alma mater he shared how growing up in
the 1960s
helped shape the course of his life it
was a decade of tumultuous social
political economic and cultural change i
understood that these rapid and
disruptive changes
could help me look at who i was
and who i should become kravis returned
to the heart of the business world
new york after an internship picking
stocks at a money management firm
his father urged him to go back to
school in 1967.
he enrolled in columbia's mba program
but his focus
was elsewhere he wanted to do deals he
wanted to make
big bucks didn't want to stay at
columbia once he got there
it was only when his former boss allowed
him to kind of keep his hand in the
business
in his spare time that henry said okay
i'll get the cotton picking degree
after college he jumped on an
opportunity presented by his first
cousin
george roberts was an analyst at the
trading shop bear stearns
but he wanted to move to san francisco
henry got his job
lewis eisenberg is one of their oldest
friends
henry and george are more than close
they can finish each other's sentences
most of the time
i've heard them disagree but they
end up coming to virtually the same
conclusions and they both share the same
brilliance for his business
though over 3 000 miles away the cousins
would work on the same team
with their boss a financial visionary
jerry colberg
henry cravis's timing was amazing in
that
he lucked into a job with his fair
fellow jerry colberg
who was doing these strange little deals
no one had heard of called
bootstrap deals later to be known much
better as leverage buyouts
kohlberg saw opportunity where other
investment bankers didn't
leverage buyout is very simple it's
where a company buys itself you strip
them down of a lot of the
excess you make them lean and mean you
borrow a lot of money
against the company's assets to pay back
that money you generally sell off the
assets
he came up with the idea of going after
family businesses
people that want to retire didn't
necessarily want to sell out to their
competition people who are very
concerned about the people that work for
them
their idea started paying off their
acquisition of industrial parts company
income international for nearly 92
million dollars
brought in the largest fee kravis said
bear stearns had ever seen
nine hundred and fifty thousand dollars
within three years kravis ran his own
deals and became a bear stearns partner
at
30 years old to make an lbo
work you can't have a trace with
sentimentality you have to be able
to slash and burn i would say henry's
skill set was ideally suited for lbos
he has a very accomplished and cold
analytical eye henry doesn't think
anything of chopping
down a ceo who doesn't deliver his
numbers
gone but an lbo's returns took
years a lifetime in the quick profit
culture of bear stearns
to say they had no patience with jerry's
deals
is like saying that it tends to get hot
in texas in summer
it was a matter of time before things
got ugly
bear stearns management rejected
kolberg's demands to start a separate
lbo department
the three men quickly decided that their
time at the legendary investment bank
was over i felt very bad about it
i've often said i don't think we worked
hard enough to keep them all on and i
must say i forget regretted it ever
since
i think it was difficult as those kind
of moves are but henry asks a lot of
questions and he asks himself a lot of
questions
but there's very little self-doubt on
the moves he makes
in 1976 henry kravis his cousin george
roberts
and their mentor jerry colberg took a
huge gamble
in a bitter parting they left the wall
street powerhouse
bear stearns we're going to start this
our own firm and we're going to just
focus on something that never been done
before it's
the time we call the bootstrap
acquisition i really want to do it
i want to do it with george we're going
to go give it a try
armed only with their novel idea to make
money
and 400 000 from backers for overhead
costs
on may 1st wall street's newest private
equity firm
kkr investments opened its doors
kravis had to immediately convince
potential investors and lbo targets
that he could post big returns richard
beatty has been an advisor to kravis
since the early 1970s
most people would say what you want to
put how much debt on this company
how can you do that pointing to his
success at bear stearns
he convinced investors to give him money
jim robinson
former chairman of american express has
been friends with kravis
for over 30 years i met this bright
young fellow who really was a very smart
investment banker who was going into a
new direction that was exciting
a new way of using wall street
mobilizing capital to go into companies
to help build the companies into even
stronger better companies
everything from the pension world to
others who are interested in being
limited partners
henry and his cousin george hunted for
companies with predictable cash flow
and potential for growth their approach
was to try to work with
existing management kravis wanted them
on board for a smooth transition
john mack is chairman of the board of
morgan stanley and has known henry
kravis for
almost 20 years he's a superb in
delivering
that speech that talk that vision
that story to a board he comes across
as knowing what he's talking about
extremely professional
he'll know the facts and he'll have a
vision that he will lay out in front of
the board
and what he's thinking why he's thinking
and what the outcome will be
he can be a force to be reckoned with
in a deal and you can see his emotion
in it in 1979 kkr made its first major
buy
auto parts maker houdai industries
at the time it was the first buyout of a
major publicly held
company in wall street history but it
would be only the first of many for
kravis kolberg and roberts
81 82 83 were terrific years gave them
credibility in the marketplace
gave him credibility with the banks or
the insurance companies
by 1983 kkr's 20 stake in each deal made
kravis a multi-millionaire
that same year kkr was raising a
record-setting investment fund
one billion dollars the innovative fund
would come to intimidate their
competitors
it was an era later summed up in one
famously simple line in the movie wall
street
greed for lack of a better word
is good and it was just getting started
in 1984 credit was easier to come by
high-risk low-rated junk bonds became
the vital engine for their lbos
junk bonds you could get them like that
the importance was the speed
it allowed henry and george to move on a
dime
overnight to come up with the financing
to make a deal work
as new deals poured in so did
invitations to glamorous new york events
kravis's second marriage to aspiring
fashion designer caroline rome
catapulted them onto the society pages
the couple often attended black tie
events with their good friend
donald trump henry was a very glamorous
figure in those
early days he was a very very
basic guy with a brilliant mind but he
always
seemed to be surrounded in glamorous
settings
kravis was now a deep-pocketed pillar of
the new york social elite
henry had no idea what the partnering
with caroline and the uh
the the appearances in the social
columns would would bring
the world looked and saw a wealthy man
they saw overreaching
and these things became symbolic of the
80s
and henry became symbolic of the 80s he
hated it
hated it hated it by 1985
kkr and henry kravis personified the
wall street boom
the private company was the most
successful leveraged buyout firm in the
world
managing an investment fund worth one
billion dollars
with their success came imitators
competition created an entirely new
world
for kkr they could no longer take the
time to sit back
and smoke a pipe with george the ceo
up in white plains suddenly deals had to
be done faster somebody else would be
doing
them for the first time henry and george
pushed kkr
into competitive deals unfriendly deals
unfriendly deals like beatrice foods the
parent company of some of america's best
known brands
in 1986 they took over the giant
conglomerate for 6.2 billion dollars
again setting records on wall street
kkr wasted no time in dismantling
beatrice
selling off division by division to pay
down the debt
kravis and his cousin did well they
earned 45 million dollars in fees
suddenly with rich fees and rewards came
a split within kkr
kravis and his mentor jerry colberg were
in a battle for the soul of their
company
on may 18 1987 jerry colberg announced
he was leaving kkr
in the press he hinted at a decline of
ethics at his former company
telling the new york times he would
stick with deals where reason still
prevails
jerry's departure was very painful for
all three for everyone it was a very sad
thing when jerry was basically shunted
aside from the business that he'd
founded
however when that did happen it left
henry and george
in clear control kravis and roberts were
exactly where they wanted to be
in clear control but they swiftly hit a
wall of trouble with beatrice foods
after stripping most of its assets to
pay down the debt
kkr was still saddled with the company's
bloated food division
kravis hungered for a new blockbuster in
1987
he found the perfect takeover candidate
rjr nabisco
the cookie and tobacco company the us's
19th largest public corporation
had a stock price trading in the 40
range
and would soon prove to be undervalued
rjr owned two giant businesses a buyer
could sell
nabisco to pay off debt and keep rjr's
hugely profitable cigarette brands
winston and camel
they have addicted customers for
christ's sake they make tons of cash
everybody wanted to do that deal and it
had a ceo
who would listen to just about anything
ross johnson was
very very generous to people he loved to
provide an airplane for somebody to go
to a golf tournament
sometimes maybe he did too many things
with rgr nabisco's assets
but he meant well f ross johnson needed
to boost his company's stagnant stock
price after the black monday market
crash of 1987
and problems with the company's new
product then there was the smokeless
cigarette by r.j reynolds
years in the making it hit the market
with an enormous
thud nothing nothing
going private with an lbo was his chance
to revive the company
not to mention make a personal fortune
the stage was set henry kravis wanted in
kravis had approached johnson with this
very idea a year before
but there was a problem you'd have a
hard time finding two corporate
executives
much different than henry kravis and
ross johnson henry is tightly controlled
and serious
and ross comes across as anything but in
terms of personal style he wears a
little
necklace and you know he's like dean
martin they were destined
to come into conflict johnson and his
management team
decided to strike out on their own and
partner with shearson lehmann an
investment bank without kkr's experience
in lbos
on october 20th 1988 they made a
proposal
a 17 billion leveraged buyout of rj
reynolds
they were offering 75 a share a nearly
20
increase over the stock price henry
kravis was outraged
the war had begun he was the king
of that business at that point and there
is no denying
that he was personally offended that
a group of little upstart nobodies to
the lbo business
could think that they could come into
his turf and take the single biggest
deal
ever proposed johnson's group tried to
make peace with kravis
but talks went nowhere just four days
later
kravis and kkr shocked the financial
world with their own bid
20 billion dollars raising the price to
90
a share henry's decision to enter the
deal
as he did it was not just big guns
coming in
it was godzilla wading in from the ocean
and stomping down wall street
he wanted to scare off potential buyers
jim robinson was head of american
express
the parent company of shearson lehman at
the time i was on the other side of the
fence
henry and george when they get
personally involved in the deals you
know that you're dealing with a very
capable adversary but the rjr board
declined kkr's offer
while johnson and his team were
blindsided by henry kravis's aggressive
move
they didn't back down they countered
with another offer of 92
dollars a share almost 21 billion
dollars
everything on wall street stopped he was
like two gun fighters out in the street
and everybody wanted to watch or
everybody wanted to grab a gun
the media they love a battle they love a
war they love a winner they love a loser
the round-the-clock publicity and the
scrutiny over the largest deal in
history
stung kravis nobody likes to see their
deal
negotiated in the press on a daily basis
and be taken out of proportion when you
play that game you're going to get
people taking shots at you you're going
to have people attack you you learn
to have a thick skin the rjr board also
rejected johnson's proposal
though to move the deal forward they
told all potential bidders that they had
10 days to come up with another offer
the confrontation between the bidders
escalated
i think henry might tell you today that
part of what was driving him
subconsciously was the desire to win the
single
most deadly sin that you can have in the
acquisitions business
six weeks after johnson's initial offer
for the giant company
kravis and roberts were locked in a
marathon last
minute bidding session their final bid
was a staggering 109 dollars a share
nearly double its initial price
now it became a waiting game there's a
lot of tension
and everybody's tired i remember it was
very late at night
when the ford finally made its decision
all over
it's all over on november 29
1988 a few minutes after 10 at night
the board of rjr had made their decision
henry kravis would win the day
kkr the best in the business and they
know what they're doing
johnson tried to engineer the biggest
inside job in history
he would have made at least 100 million
dollars
for his own personal bank account if the
deal had worked
but a wall street tycoon named henry
kravis
snatched the company away and that's it
for mr johnson
kkr made 75 million dollars in fees
clearly winning rjr took henry to the
pinnacle of his reputation
on wall street but more than anything i
know from talking with them at the time
that mostly what they felt was fear fear
that they were not going to be able to
make this work
ultimately those fears proved well
founded
[Music]
kkr were the winners in the epic
business battle for rjr nabisco
but for henry kravis the spoils were
short-lived they ultimately won
that prize over the long run it did not
turn out as well as
one might have hoped the aftermath of
the mega deal
was catastrophic it had not worked out
perfectly and there was a lot of
pressure to get this thing right and
make a return for their investors
the firm is often congratulated on on
acquiring making a large acquisition
and he's always said save it
congratulate me when we get out
in 1991 while trying to take rjr
out of its tailspin kravis faced a
family tragedy
harrison his 19 year old son from a
previous marriage
was killed in a car crash his life
hasn't been simple his personal life
has had a strong sense of tragedy losing
his son you can try and imagine but you
can't really go there
two years later kravis was splashed all
over the tabloids when he divorced his
wife of seven years
carolyn rome he remarried marie jose
druan
a prominent economist and philanthropist
by 1995 cigarette price wars and tobacco
litigation had crushed rjr's profits
generating a dismal annual rate of
return of less than one percent
kkr decided it was no longer worth
holding on to the corporate giant
they unloaded their investment and one
of wall street's most
storied battles the rjr nabisco buyout
came to a close you asked whether the
rjr deal is wall street's finest
i don't think anybody would call it its
finest hour i think if anything
someone argued that it was its worst
hour its lowest hour its most demeaning
hour an hour when
all the things all the stereotypes that
main street in america believes about
wall street that
that it's doing things for ego and greed
seems
so demonstrably true to the rest of the
country
after some rocky deals in the 90s kravis
and kkr
struggled in 2001 one of their holdings
regal cinemas went bankrupt costing them
half a billion dollars bloodied but
unbowed
kravis admitted they needed to change
the way they did business
and after years of rebuilding were once
again making headlines
in 2006 they bought the hospital chain
hca
valued at 33 billion dollars jason kelly
is a private equity reporter at
bloomberg news
kkr beat it with the hta deal in 2006.
then kkr beat that record
with the txu deal in 2007. so they came
back
and they came back fierce in 2007
they began a three-year effort to list
the company on the new york stock
exchange
finally going public with a
disappointing debut in 2010
going public is an extraordinarily
difficult decision for these guys to
make
what's uncomfortable for this firm that
that he and george have built over the
years
is showing any part of the secret sauce
to the public
kkr's portfolio includes 58 companies
and manages assets totaling over 55
billion dollars
but even that doesn't quite capture the
breadth of what they hold
218 billion dollars in revenue
across the companies that they own from
toy retailers to power producers in
texas
to hospital chains look there are two
types of guys on wall street those that
retire to florida and
those that don't clearly one of the
things that's most important to him is
his legacy i don't think there's ever
the expectation that every ball is going
to be hit out of the park
but if there's a place that can hit
every ball out of the park he's
developing a team
with a deep bench at kkr and they're
going to hit a lot of balls out of the
park
if you've got a hope and a belief and a
dream
follow it no matter what henry is an
absolute pioneer
he's an innovator he's an icon like
morgan like the rockefellers henry's a
great guy
with an unbelievable instinct for what's
going to happen into the future
he can look and just see it better than
almost everybody
and that's an awfully good trait when it
comes to business